la gauche avait percé au premier tour
des élections législatives la gauche
confirme son retour dans les yvelines la
nouvelle union populaire écologique et
social aura deux députés yves binois
l'assemblée nationale suite aux
élections législatives d'abord dans la
8e circonscription benjamins lucas
s'impose largement j'ai fait campagne
depuis des semaines auprès des habitants
et des habitants pour convaincre pour
mobiliser parce que j'ai entendu des
souffrances parce que j'ai entendu aussi
des envies des attentes des aspirations
qui correspondait je crois à ce que je
portais à ce que nous portions dans
cette campagne sur le pouvoir d'achat
sur la justice sociale notamment sur le
respect et la dignité pour chacune et
pour chacun donc ça ne me surprend pas
c'est l'ampleur du résultat qui me
surprend en revanche parce qu'il est
très large et plus large que ce que je
croyais pas ce qu'a fait la différence
c'est qu'on a fait campagne
d'arrache-pied qu'on est allé voir des
milliers de gens qu'on a frappé à des
milliers de portes que qu'on a échangé
qu'on a écouté ça a été une campagne de
dialogue une campagne d'idées en tête
lors du premier tour le candidat de
l'ani ps récolte 5000 voix
supplémentaires au second tour sur
l'ensemble de la circonscription à
mantes la jolie le dépasse les 60% avec
une abstention plus faible qu'au premier
tour
1759 moi
même phénomène dans la 11e
circonscription où williams martinez
devient le député de ce territoire il
devance la candidate de la majorité
présidentielle
aurélie pia senza 217 voix seulement
notre réservoir de voix c'était les
abstentionnistes n'y avait rien
d'automatique et de et de mécanique pour
pouvoir faire plus de 50% des voix il a
fallu retourner sur le terrain et à
réussir à convaincre à la fois de nos
propositions mais ça c'était pas le plus
difficile le smic à 1500 euros la
retraite à 60 ans le blocage des prix
c'est des mesures qui sont majoritaires
ultra majoritaire dans le pays ce qui a
été le plus difficile c'est de
convaincre qu'il était possible de
gagner bien entendu il est arrivé en
tête à trappes qui est la première ville
de la circonscription donc c'est ce qui
a fait l'écart entre
a priori sur sur les résultats attrape
le candidat de la nouvelle récolte 78%
des suffrages avec une participation
plus importante par rapport au premier
tour sur l'ensemble de la 11e
circonscription williams martinez gagne
un peu moins de 5000 voix par rapport au
premier scrutin